Michael Oscar great to see you guys
thanks so much for joining us okay so in
the ring you got to be competitors right
and you're fighting but outside you're
both together promoting so how do you
cooperate outside the ring well we're in
we're on the same page where our goal is
to make sure that this event is as
successful then the Manny Pacquiao
Mayweather fight for instance our goal
is to make sure people know about Cotto
Canelo and hopefully on November 21st
they they buy the fight because it's a
great fight right um to see who the best
middleweight champion in the world is so
we there's a collaboration there's a
friendship first and foremost but our
goal is to is to you know to say we have
the same message go out there and and
promote this event I think that's the
key I mean from day one you know and
when Oscar and I talked about this fight
we said you know what we have common
goals and objectives right let's make it
the best in the biggest fight of the
year and quite frankly you know we've
stayed very consistent with that
throughout the entire time five six
months and here we are you know ten days
before the fight and you know it's very
very exciting we think we're well
positioned to achieve the goals and
objectives right and there's no question
this is the fight of the year so it's
it's gonna be a great night on the
burner 21st now Oscar the pacquiao
Mayweather fight though a lot of height
beforehand and then the fans got
disappointed right the actual match the
bite and so do you are you worried that
that has left a bad taste in people's
mouths and that might affect the
enthusiasm for this fight no no no
nothing whatsoever I mean we feel that
people know this is a real fight people
know that this is a stylistically this
is a fight that is gonna be guaranteed
action no matter what Miguel Cotto is a
warrior he's a fighter who just goes in
straight in throws a lot of punches has
a great Qin Canelo my guy he's he's the
young bull the the fighter who's uh just
as strong right he has to appreciate
younger he's ten years young yeah
so this is one of those fights where it
can't miss and people know that so what
I'm thinking is Manny Pacquiao
Mayweather generated 4.8 million homes
pay-per-view homes at one hundred
dollars a pop so what we did here was /
surprised in half and if we generate
half the business that if I did then
when great Jake then you're then you're
making absolutely but Michael how do you
get you know I know HBO is promoting
this heavily but how do you get Joe
Sixpack to pay even fifty sixty dollars
on pay-per-view well listen we've built
up this this event as one of the biggest
events of the year we've got one of the
best promoters in the business and Oscar
who's been talking about the fight and
obviously he's been a part of some huge
fights right you know it's got a bet
with jay-z yes yes and that's another
way that we that we're really
penetrating the mainstream you know that
bet was you know something that that we
felt was important both you know jay-z
and Oscar are very passionate about
their fighters and so they wanted to put
some money on the table yeah but you
know we've got a very very comprehensive
marketing campaign we're talking about
the fight as much as we possibly can the
media is excited about the fight and
it's it's not just for the hardcore
boxing fan this is a huge event and in
order to get to the numbers that Oscar
and I believe we can get to between one
and two million pay-per-views we really
need support from the mainstream and we
think that this fight and the excitement
of the fight will be attractive to the
mainstream audience Oscar you know
there's some talk though that boxing you
know the generation the new generation
of fans are not as interested in boxing
as they are in mixed martial arts right
so the MMA fighters are now really
popular and that maybe boxing's on the
wane I know you put what Ronda Rousey on
the cover of really is right that caused
a little bit of a stir do you think I
mean is this where you are headed you
know in terms of your promotions do you
want to start bringing MMA into in you
know into your area well it's it's all
about thinking outside the box the
younger generation doesn't want to be
told for instance what to watch or
or you know they want to think outside
the box and think you know differently
and so what we're doing now is more of
the social media initiative frame and
that's going to be a big boost for the
fight for instance we're calling up all
our friends who have millions and
millions of followers with whether it's
on Twitter whether it's on Facebook
right instagram and so we're doing this
initiative see that and you see that
with the MMA fighters absolutely there's
opulent social media but you want you
want to promote Ronda Rousey well my
thing is if she's ever convinced that
she can become world champion which I
think she is can become world champion
in boxing right then give me at all I'll
be more than happy to provide it's a
win-win for everybody I mean she's
amazing she's incredible she's and and
the idea behind putting her in Ring
Magazine was because she is starting to
learn the boxing game she does want to
become world champion in boxing so I
know she has a concert with the UFC but
the day she wants to become a boxer then
we're right here waiting for then you
never know absolutely he's pre-selling
right he's first in line for sure and I
can't let you guys go and particularly
Oscar you go without asking about Floyd
Mayweather who says he's retired he's 49
oh right um do you think he's really
done I mean you know what you go through
when you retire as an athlete right and
we don't think he's done no not at all I
strongly believe he's gonna fight a few
more times not just one more time but I
just think he's gonna fight a couple
more times and you know I believe
they're gonna wait till next year maybe
do the rematch with Pacquiao and and
then we'll see what happens but if it
the money or is it something else well
it's all business for Mayweather that's
all it is or his team is it's all about
business it's not about see that's the
difference with our fight here November
21st it's about passion it's about the
fans it's about giving the fans the best
fight possible and that's what the
fighters are gonna do inside the ring is
give you a war it's gonna be amazing
incredible yes it is about a business
yeah but it's about the fight first okay
and when you say it's the business for
him what do you mean exactly it's well
it's all money that okay low risk
reward us here I mean yes we're not I
mean we're not naive here but we do want
to make money but it's all about making
sure the fans are happy all right Oscar
great to see you thank you so much and
also Michael great to see you as well
thank you guys for stopping by thank you